people studying light and get all
excited about the possibility of getting
10 kilovolt x-rays out of whitening and
here we can feel tape and get 50
kilovolt x-rays out of peeling tape at
the university of california los angeles
seth Putterman Carlos Kamara and Juan
Escobar with their colleague Jonathan
Hurd have been releasing some of the
energy locked up in the surfaces of
things you'll see electron some of the
time looking as though they're announced
dates and some of the time looking as
though they're whizzing around sometimes
the surface will look like it's
insulating and at times it will turn
into a conducting surface due to
stirring up all the ions and electrons
we've been very much interested in
natural phenomena that concentrate
energy density in the 1600s it was
discovered that when you scrub mercury
against the walls of a barometer tube
flashes of light come from where the
mercury meets the walls and it turns out
that this is due to spectacularly
catastrophic events at surfaces of
interaction in Russia in the 1930s
abramoff suggested that splitting mica
might produce bursts of energy and in
the 1950s carousel first suggested that
peeling tape could produce x-rays though
few believed him at the time it would be
a fantastic energy focusing phenomena if
by peeling tape or splitting mica you
could turn the small mechanical force
required to split the mica or the small
force required to peel tape into x-rays
and so basically we said this is too
good to be true we want to see it for
ourselves I personally got involved for
exactly that same reason I did not
believe it as we know when we rub a comb
through our hair we can then attract
little piece of paper that's because
charge has been attached to the to the
comb from our hair and the opposite
charge has been attached to our hair and
in a Van de Graaff machine rubbing
surface
uses a similar effect so here we have
spectacular discharges between the
charge accumulating there and ground
over here it's probably generating
x-rays and then you have a mechanism of
discharge which is in the case of a
lightning strike is the fuel the energy
has become so enormous that there is a
breakdown and the air becomes conductive
and all these electrons rush down and
discharge you can get voltages of a
hundred thousand volts and we had heard
that adhesives could do something
similar and we didn't believe it at
first and so for example if you have
just tape and you open it you see that
it's charged right so you can it can
move towards my hand because of the
charge that is left we also heard that
it was possible that that would generate
x-rays so this is our vacuum chamber and
as you can see we just go from one reel
to another reel there it is and I can
see the motor go off here we have the
tape that's getting unrolled the
scintillator sensitive to high energy
electrons now we're going to turn on the
vacuum and remove those gas particles
from around the tape
Beckerman has to be in vacuum because if
it's not and you will have gas particles
around it that will make the surfaces
discharge before you can separate them
to a point where the potential is large
enough to generate x-rays we're going to
about the pressure that a thousandth of
a millimeter of mercury would have under
the force of gravity on a birth these
are electrons as a tape these feeling
are being ejected and it's those same
electrons that when they hit the other
side of the tape are going to generate
the X rays so this is a Geiger counter
and we're going to see if we turn it off
or a second okay there's actually
nothing there but as soon as you turn it
on
we are seen in yoga
now the motor is actually not peeling
the tape that fast we're peeling it at
about say five centimeters a second
that's really you know about this fast
so it's not like we're really ripping it
with tremendous force and yet there's
enough charge there and enough discharge
of electron that this enormous flux of
x-rays comes out enough actually to our
surprise to take an x-ray picture with
peeling tape as a source what we have
over here is x-ray film and it's pretty
simple with this same setup you can put
your finger and then put the x-ray film
on top and then maybe take another one
and do it on this section of the finger
and then another one on this section of
the finger and then when we develop the
film you can actually see an image of
the finger this is the same x-ray film
that is used by dentists now there
you're connected to an enormous x-ray
machine in fact the dentist usually
leaves the room when they fire it and
here we have a remarkably simple
alternative to that which is capable of
developing the same film and we've
looked at it with a microscope and it's
really a messy there are all filaments
it's a very complicated process this
gooey thing unsticks I find it amazing
that you've got this complex tangle of
strings at the vertex of the peeling
tape which is about a hundred microns in
this picture and out of this complex
motion you get a collective blast of a
hundred thousand x-ray photons in merely
10 to the minus nine a billionth of a
second I don't understand how such a
cooperative phenomena takes place this
is the cheapest way to generate x-rays
at this scale have these devices in
third world countries where electricity
is a very expensive commodity where
[Music]
it's not that easy to get an x-ray what
you're seeing here today is what we got
with the first roll of tape that we used
I propose that by studying various
adhesives and what's going on and
learning what's happening here
improvements of a factor of 10 or 100
could be made so now especially for
nature video today they're trying out a
new type of tape so let's give it a
whirl
ok does it have a different feel to it
really it really looks about the same
okay
you
oh there you go yes there's light at
least there's a lot of light like maybe
works better
[Music]
yeah I never felt still gonna turn it
out I'm getting scared let me go let me
go and it's coming right from the vertex
yeah we've got our factor of 10 right
here very bright that's incredible
[Music]
[Music]
you